three out of five cabinet appointees
agree paying your taxes is good for you
in fact recent studies have indicated
that failing to correctly file your
taxes can lead to devastating health and
career problems in 1931 the bootlegger
and Chicago mobster Al Capone was
sentenced to federal prison not for
illegal alcohol sales operating
whorehouses or even orchestrating the
st. Valentine's Day Massacre he was put
in jail for income tax evasion 15 years
later he died from complications related
to syphilis in 1987 actor Wesley Snipes
appeared in a Michael Jackson video
launching a promising film career in
2008 Snipes was found guilty of willful
failure to file federal income tax
returns now he can only find work in
infomercials for the total gym 1,000
at the start of 2008 Timothy Franz
Geithner was the President of the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York making
over a third of a million dollars a year
later it was revealed he owed back taxes
now he has to work for the Obama
administration
you